il ne fallait pas être en retard au
stade gilbert chance ac pour le
troisième tour de coupe de france assez
fou entre trappe
et là c'est boulogne billancourt
première incursion des trappistes dans
le camp de la cbd premier penalty sifflé
en forme et dans l'afflux est dans le
petit filet cueillis à froid la cvb
pensionnaire de division d'honneur ne
tarde pas à répondre sur son coup franc
dévié au premier poteau par le capitaine
lassana conté
mais avant la mi temps la défense
trappistes malgré une belle résistance
c'est d'une seconde fois sur cette
frappe enroulée du pied droit de maxime
bouet à l'entamé du dernier quart
d'heure trappe réduit le square à
nouveau sur penalty
c'est alors que le match s'emballe ou
pas un non pas deux mais quatre buts
sont marqués dans les dernières minutes
de l'armée a vécu à 10 la marche était
trop haute pour le club yvelinois
battus 5 à 3